Let's try to subtract
9.57 minus 8.09.
So try to pause this video
and figure this out first
before we work
through it together.
All right.
Well, let's just rewrite it.
Let's rewrite it.
And when I rewrite it, I
like to line up the decimals.
This one it's a
little intuitive.
We have 8.09.
Just like that, and now
we're ready to subtract.
And we want to subtract 9
hundredths from 7 hundredths.
Well, we don't have
enough hundredths
up here so let's move over here.
Let's see if we can do some
regrouping so we always
have a higher number on top.
So over here we want to
subtract 0 tenths from 5 tenths
so we have enough
tenths over here.
So let's regroup.
So instead of 5 tenths,
I'm going to have 4 tenths,
and then I'm going to give
that other tenth, which
is the same thing as 10
hundredths over here,
so this becomes 17 hundredths.
17 minus 9 is 8.
4 minus 0 is 4.
And then I have 9 minus 8 is 1.
So this is going to be 1.48.